-It's great to see you.
You know, Christine Baranski
was here last night.
She showed a clip
from the movie.
I watched that clip -- you all
seem like you're having so fun.
You guys were
just stealing money.
-It's ridiculous.
We were just --
We were getting paid to, like,
frolic again...
-Yeah.
-...10 years later.
-Because that's not CGI.
You were on a real island.
-No, I know.
And, God, our DP is amazing.
Dude, he, like,
really captured it.
It feels like you're there.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I've watched it twice.
I feel like I'm brought back.
-It really is --
I didn't know what ABBA music
looked like, but it is that.
-Yeah!
Yes, it's candy.
-It's, like, that's what
I thought the whole time,
but I didn't know
until you showed it.
-I know.
-It was like, "Yes!
It was that boat."
-It's like a drug.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask more about
the movie, but I also want --
Because we have
a very similar situation.
You have a dog
you love to death,
who's a bit
of an Instagram celebrity.
This is your dog, Finn?
Right?
-Yep.
-There she is.
-He, he, he, he.
-And, Finn, it's a boy's name,
so I should've known that.
And you also have a small child.
-I do.
-About 16 months old, right?
-Yep. Yeah.
-8-year-old dog, 16-month-old.
-Oh, God.
-We have very similar situation
with our age,
children and our dog.
-Yeah.
-Are the dog and the child
getting along?
-I mean, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She loves him so much.
And he...tolerates her so much.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This looks like a dog
that's tolerating [bleep]
-Yeah, he's really cool
around her.
He plays it cool.
He hasn't licked her yet.
But, yeah,
it's gonna be fine.
In like 10 years,
they're gonna love each other.
-That's great.
[ Laughter ]
-And, you know,
until then, it's fine.
I'll just have another kid.
-And has your --
Be honest, has your love for
Finn waned even an inch?
-No, I love them
the same amount.
-Okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
-They are --
he's got his stuff that I love.
She's got her stuff.
It's -- yeah, no.
They all say that.
They're like, "You're gonna
forget about your dog,"
but I haven't.
He's very much...
-A big part of your life still.
-He's very much my firstborn.
-That's very sweet.
We do say that
about our dog, as well.
-You do?
Yeah, of course.
-And people think we're weird.
Yeah.
-It's not weird.
They teach you how to parent.
I think it's important.
-I do think they do teach you
how to parent.
I agree.
And I just wish we could
put some food in a bowl
in the morning
and be done with our kids
the same way.
[ Laughter ]
-I know, there's a lot of perks.
-Yeah, there's a lot of perks.
-To just having pets.
-To this species,
figured out a lot stuff.
-Yeah.
-We saw you doing
some dancing in the film.
Obviously, you had to dance
a lot in the first one, as well.
Would you classify yourself
as a good dancer?
-No.
-Okay.
-I wanted to be,
but it's really hard.
-Yeah.
-It's a hard thing to do.
-And I would imagine, you know,
obviously you have the cast,
and one of the big things
you're choosing with your cast
is how good of actors they are,
but everybody else in the movie
they cast to be good dancers.
So, is it hard for you to be
around professional dancers?
-Yeah, because they've got it
all right.
Like, the timing is all about
me getting my lines,
me getting the moves right,
and the music,
you know, doesn't stop.
And so it's all on me
to get it right
'cause they're
all professionals,
and they're doing it perfectly.
They gave me a lot less dancing,
by the way...
-Oh, second movie.
-...to be fair, on this movie.
-Oh, interesting.
Did you take that as a --
them having watched
the first one a couple times?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I take it as them
knowing that I'm probably
never gonna get it right.
Which is absolutely fine
with me.
-Are there other people
in the cast that are sort of
on your level,
as far as how good a dancer?
-Yeah, I don't think --
I don't think Pierce is,
you know, a dancer.
He's an actor.
-Yeah.
-I would say the same
about Stellan.
Colin, for sure, doesn't...
[ Laughter ]
-...enjoy it.
-Cher is in the film.
-Yeah.
-Cher plays your grandmother.
What is it like to
just even be in Cher's aura?
-Oh, God.
It's a dream.
I cried when I found out she
was gonna play my grandmother.
-Uh-huh.
-And when she came on set,
she was just like --
just so cool.
She's so cool.
She's like a young woman,
just kind of, you know --
She was kind of
intimidated by us.
-Uh-huh.
-And we were intimidated by her,
and then she came on set,
and we saw her fear,
and I think we could all
relate to each other.
It's like we're all humans
at the end of the day,
but, God, she's cool.
-Yeah.
-But she's Cher.
But, God, she's so cool.
[ Laughter ]
But she's Cher.
-Right, yeah.
-How is she -- She's --
I can't get over it.
-No matter how cool --
She can't be so cool
that she stops being Cher.
That's, like --
-That's true.
-That's the paradox of her life.
-Maybe that's
what makes her Cher?
-Yeah.
She can't escape it.
-Maybe that's
what makes her Cher.
She's so cool!
-I feel like if this
was "Mamma Mia!" right now,
you and I would break into song.
-I would!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ Maybe that's why ♪♪
♪♪ She's Cher ♪♪
-But we don't have music.
-We don't need to do that.
-I don't know.
I would, though, for you.